[Musique]
c'est marrant mais j'ai un drôle de
feeling c'est un petit peu comme les
black eyed peas i gotta feeling
d'altadis boarding gonna be good et
bichonnent jeu il le sent que ça va
partir en cacahuète d'ici quelques temps
à cinq millions de dollars c'est le
chiffre du jour et c'est la somme
colossale qu'à paris un mystérieux
citoyens britanniques sur la victoire de
trump et il pourrait remporter ces
président américain est réélu trois fois
sa mise initiale
c'est le montant le plus important
jamais misé dans le cadre d'un pari
politique doit être un peu sûr de lui il
affiche fièrement l'autocollant qu'ils
ont reçus après avoir voté
chaque état a son propre aux stickers
j'ai voté sur les réseaux sociaux ils
sont partout comme le hashtag du même
nom très populaires ces dernières heures
des célébrités jouent le jeu
jennifer lopez kim kardashian ou encore
beyoncé en ont quasiment fait de
l'accessoire de mode incontournable du
moment je n'ai jamais rencontré des
grands criminels mais j'ai jamais
rencontrées non plus de sa loi intégrale
j'aie jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui en
se levant le matin était un sale type
jusqu'au moment où au soir où il
s'endort et une part d'humanité chez
tous les êtres humains
enfin je crois
kanye west aussi à voter pour lui parce
que rappelons le il s'est présenté à
cette élection
au vu des premiers résultats il le sait
il ne sera pas élu mais le rappeur n'a
pas dit son dernier mot
il se prépare déjà pour 2024 à en croire
ce tweet il ya un chiffre à retenir
vingt-quatre mille tweets en quatre ans
une véritable frénésie qui n'a fait que
s'accentuer
donald trump publiait en moyenne sept
messages par jour lors de sa première
année à la maison blanche
mais depuis le début 2020 il est sur une
moyenne de 35 tweets par jour des tweets
de toutes sortes mais essentiellement à
sa propre gloire mais aussi des attaques
directes contre ses adversaires le new
york times a recensé 598 victimes
directes des foudres de trump tu parles
du son et le sens
il ya bien les a pas écoutés
en tout cas on va s'intéresser aux
anneaux parmi les mots qu'il a le plus
utilisé sur twitter en quatre ans on
trouve les termes loser idiot et stupide
autre spécialité de trump on sait
l'effet news les propos mensongers aux
complotistes
selon le washington post au cours de son
mandat donald trump a publié 3885 tweets
contenant de fausses informations ça
fait à peu près un tweet sur cinq
franchement deux là vont gagner cette
élection
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous souhaitons que la loi sera
appliquée correctement
nous irons à la cour suprême ne
souhaitons que les potes vole un peu
ambitieux ce qu'on peut faire de sa vie
votre que paraît pas ce qu'on essaie de
convaincre les gens de manger d'arrêter
de manger les biens industriels de
prendre un peu moins l'avion de voix la
graphie je déconnais pendant beaucoup
donné mais on peut toujours devenir
meilleur regardez ce tweet ensemble un
cours de yoga gratuit écouter en quoi ça
consiste
commencez par vous penchez puis ramasser
le masque que vous avez jeté par terre
cette posture de base est connue sous le
nom de je ne suis pas un imbécile
vraiment je suis assez fatigué de castex
qui est pour moi c'est un peu le
christiane gré de la politique je passe
une connectique si vous connaissiez
christiane gré je n'arriverais quoi 50
nièce de 50 nuance degrés à toi que tu
le dis c'est toujours le fouet à la main
il a toujours le don chauny est à la
bouche ou à la main à la bouche même
avec sa bouche
non
demain tous et sur le micro de son
téléphone pourrait nous permettre de
savoir si je suis porteur ou non de
lakovic 19 donc c'est à boston que les
chercheurs du et mighty massachusetts
institute of technology hong lei oui
c'est l'anglais mais massachusetts s'est
jamais vraiment évident on développer
une intelligence artificielle capable
donc de détecter la présence du virus
dans l'analyse automatique de la toux
[Musique]
car ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
modulations de l'atout d'une personne en
bonne santé sont complètement
différentes des modulations d'une
personne qui seraient atteintes par le
virus le problème c'est que ça à
l'oreille humaine
on n'arrive pas à le percevoir mais
l'outil du et mighty lui parviendrait à
faire la différence et se serait selon
eux quasiment infaillible
le confinement saison 2 on en pense quoi
on en pense qu'on n'a pas envie de
connaître la saison 3 comparé à beaucoup
de seuils
on a perdu en france je le dis souvent
80% ça c'est des insectes volants à
cause des pesticides sans doute 80% des
insectes volants
c'est inimaginable et avec ça on a perdu
30 % des oiseaux parce que se
nourrissent d'insectes le selon le
dernier rapport du vfc un chiffre
invraisemblable on aurait perdu en 50
ans 70% du vivant sur la terre
je suis parti je suis arrivé là-bas au
magasin dégage comprend rien expliqué
moto images y voilà
tant de kilos ça c'est en ça c'est pour
les couettes rumbo les plus grands le
mounchid avions non le il ya eu de l'eau
dans une machine à laver
non mais attends bourrique non je dis
que la porte ça s'appelle hublot
l'argentin peut-être une autre et
argentine merci laurent au fait
l'argentine c'est où exactement
bon là pierre olivier les filles se noie
et où la maison non theobald objectif
top chef
alors tu sois en tee shirt tablier et
amateurs n'y a pas de problème mais le
minimum c'est de mettre un pantalon
fouet ces dentistes
quand il va dans son cabinet au string
vanessa quand on le perd et bien on
tombe un membre elle a pas tord
s'arrêter mais c'est vrai et aujourd'hui
que je vous montre comment renforcer
votre poignet c'est important peu de
tout un programme pour lass c'est
l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est la
coiffure on peut s'en passer mais
l'épilation fou que ça reste merci c'est
simple c'est beaucoup de peine de
terminer